I think people have taken the Eli
because people in this community were
always looking for something to be
passionate about before he like came we
had people that said it couldn't be done
but through perseverance we want a
county championship and basketball
I'm Eli Brooks my dad is with my coach
for my whole life
[Music]
I'm James Burris in the Spring Grove
boys basketball codes
my dad started coaching me I was in
first grade while I wasn't allowed to
play on the white team Spring Grove is
sold around the papermill the community
is really close to passionate about
their sports but last time we want a
championship snakes in seminary they
were looking for something to cheer for
what I love about basketball is a team
work in the friendships I made but
teaches a lot of things treating people
the right way taking care of the younger
kids that are looking up to me making
sure my actions are in line with what my
parents have taught me saying goodbye to
Spring Grove it's going to be hard
my dad is when my basketball coach for
10 years now I learned so much from him
throughout basketball and just life
experiences it will be exciting to see
Eli and his cap and gown getting dressed
up put you in a frame of mind of
maturity
I just wanted to the excitement on my
parents faces when I walked across the
stage
I'm my dad's child pretty much so that's
gonna be tough for him we did a lot of
things together that are just like
everyday things but I think he'll
missile I think it's important that he
goes out and ventures and shows
everybody else that he is that special
kid I'm sure me and his mom will cry I'm
proud to be your dad you've taken our
community to a place it has never seen
why am I getting choked up for the
camera make me please shut down I'm
going to continue on coach next year
everybody's encouraged one from one
local making it to a big University
I think that my dad's coming back for
another season just shows his commitment
to the community the ball stops bouncing
at some point probably the biggest thing
that you can get out of sports just
interactions with other people you
really have to give back to your
community with the EAP you